[Applauso]
[Musica]
ho dedicato gran parte della mia vita
a difendere il digitale prima come
studente poi come ricercatore oggi come
imprenditore e manager perché credo che
il digitale se opportunamente
interpretato possa essere uno strumento
di umanizzazione
sì certo può sembrare abbastanza
simpatico abbastanza singolare di solito
il digitale è in contrapposizione
all'essere umano ma non è forse grazie
al digitale che abbiamo raggiunto degli
obiettivi impensabili e una qualità di
vita mai raggiunta prima proviamo a
pensare
al ruolo del digitale durante questa
pandemia e grazie a digitale che siamo
riusciti a continuare abbiamo potuto
abbia avuto la possibilità di continuare
a imparare
ed è grazie al digitale che i nonni
hanno avuto l'opportunità di continuare
a guardare i nipoti ma proviamo a
immaginare ea capire anche quello che
sta succedendo oggi con i nuovi sistemi
biometrici
sistemi che possiamo indossare o di cui
possiamo dotarci faccio riferimento a
peacemaker interconnessi e a pompe di
insulina e interconnesse che nel momento
in cui identificano che qualcosa non va
nel nostro corpo automaticamente ci
aiutano ecco questo digitale che ho
difeso e questo digitale che voglia
difendere e nel mentre che difendevo
questo digitale sono sempre entrato in
contatto con degli strumenti particolari
con degli oggetti particolari con di
sistemi che prendono il nome di malware
ovvero malicious a want software
degli artefatti realizzati dagli
attaccanti e poi inoculati all'interno
dei sistemi vittima per cambiarne il
comportamento per carpire dati o per
farle cambiare e a compiere azioni
malevole ecco è
proprio come un chirurgo che ha la
possibilità operando un corpo di
guardare il suo interno io ho sempre
avuto la possibilità di guardare
all'interno di questi malware ne conosco
i bit ne conosco i baiting losco il
source code ma non ho mai avuto
l'opportunità di capire come questi
oggetti interagiscono col mondo esterno
visivamente
ecco l'intuizione l'intuizione
di gruppi di scienziati di creare degli
algoritmi di visione artificiale capace
di visualizzare dei codici di
visualizzare dei sistemi binari ecco
allora che cosa ho fatto ho preso dei
malware e li ho fatti visualizzare da
questi sistemi
beh il risultato per me è stato
incredibile è stato come se per la prima
volta avesse avuto la possibilità di
vedere questi malware prendere forma un
po come se camminassero intorno a me ho
avuto l'opportunità di guardarli negli
occhi per la prima per la prima volta
così ne ho scelti tre e ve li vorrei
presentare
i motel un malware molto importante per
noi è molto importante perché nella
storia è stato uno dei malware più
longevi più di dieci anni a questo
soggetto
all'inizio era un sì un semplice info
stile rossi a carpiva informazioni poi
nel corso degli anni è stato modificato
ed è stato migliorato fino ad essere
diventato un sistema inoculato re quindi
grazie ai motel altri attaccanti
riuscivano a inoculare altri malware
all'interno delle vittime e lo si può
vedere perché abbiamo come una faccia
esterna un cubo esterno che rappresenta
un po come una maschera che hai poi
invece un vero comportamento quello
interno con un cuore pulsante differente
con una colorazione anche molto
eclatante rispetto
i motel e anche molto importante perché
è stato il primo grande malware nella
storia che ha unito
forze di polizia
internazionali per
ucciderlo per colpirlo per estirparlo
pochi pochi mesi fa
numerose forze di polizie internazionali
organizzazioni si sono accordate hanno
scovato dove era nascosto ed hanno
tagliato l'anno spento
come abbiamo cripto locker keep the
rocker molto famoso nel nostro ambiente
perché assieme a un buon akrai è stato
uno di quei malware che ha cambiato la
storia
almeno secondo il mio personale punto di
vista cioè è stato insieme a buona cry
il primo malware a incominciare a
chiedere un riscatto questo malumore
prende nome di ramsauer nella realtà
iran sommer sono noti sin dagli anni 80
ma cripto locker e buona cry sono stati
quelli che per il primo anno aperto gli
occhi a tutti una volta il la sicurezza
informatica era una cosa di pochi eletti
oggi con clips rocker e monac rai tutti
sanno che c'è questo problema tutti
sanno che c'è questo tema a dover stare
attenti come potete come si può
facilmente vedere dalle immagini è molto
semplice cripto locker e genuino
nasconde niente al suo interno cosa
diversa invece per mail mese incredibile
perché non soltanto rivoluzionato il
mondo del malware passando dalla singola
estorsione their answer alla doppia
estorsione quindi se prima era
sufficiente pagare un riscatto per
riavere i propri file
oggi pagare un riscatto non è più
sufficiente
c'è la necessità di pagare due riscatti
per evitare che i file vengono cifrati e
che non vengono ritornati al
proprietario e per evitare che essi
vengono pubblicati ma mesi ci ha dato
anche un'altra grande
visione ci ha aperto gli occhi
perché mese
non è un sistema criminale basato su una
singola persona o si può su pochi
persone ma mese è una sistema criminale
generalizzato e globale formato su
organizzazioni quindi non abbiamo un
singolo attaccante un singolo un singolo
criminale abbiamo un'organizzazione
strutturata con sviluppatori di software
che sviluppano questi malware con dei
sistemi affiliati che prendono il
malware lo inoculo nelle vittime con dei
professionisti
negoziatori per negoziare il riscatto
l'ha con me è stato importante anche per
questo ed è molto complesso è un sistema
ad analizzare difficile al suo interno
nasconde tante funzionalità
cosa possiamo fare oggi
con queste informazioni sono solo
informazioni belle da vedere e che hanno
emozionato un un povero analista dei
malware o invece possiamo fare qualcosa
ma proviamo ad immaginare ora se
avessimo l'opportunità di avere decine
centinaia milioni di queste immagini
proviamo a immaginare di avere tutti i
malware che conosciamo
visualizzati in questo modo magari
giustificati per famiglie e perché no
anche
classificati in funzione del tempo
quindi ciò che è avvenuto prima rispetto
a ciò che è venuto dopo
ecco in questo momento
ricercatori e comunità scientifica
stanno studiando se è possibile
applicare algoritmi e intelligenza
artificiale su questi sistemi visuali
per andare a predire quello che accadrà
dopo quindi in funzione di quello che è
accaduto andare a immaginare quale sarà
il prossimo volto la prossima figura del
prossimo malware e poi a quel punto
potremo cercare di identificare una
soluzione per andare sintetizzare quello
che abbiamo scoperto per identificare e
per bloccare il malware sul nascere
viviamo in un mondo molto
molto importante molto veloce viviamo in
un mondo in cui
tutto cambia molto molto velocemente e
se ci pensiamo questa idea è un'idea che
è già stata applicata anche
in altre discipline proviamo a pensare a
quello che è successo con the next
rembrandt una rete neurale che è stata
educata
attraverso a delle immagini a dei
dipinti dipinti di iren brown e una
volta che esso è stata educata
attraverso questi dipinti i ricercatori
hanno chiesto beh ora gas è il
principale esperto di rembrandt dimmi
quale sarà il prossimo dipinto che
potrebbe fare
la rete neurale ha risposto dicendo un
mezzo busto a quel punto hanno
continuato bene ma sei tu il massimo
esperto
disegnato il dipinto è così la rete
neurale ha risposto con un disegno con
un dipinto un dipinto mai fatto da
rembrandt ma che probabilmente avrebbe
potuto fare
questo che cosa dimostra dimostra che il
cambiamento tecnologico il cambiamento
del digitale è così importante che
quando tocca poi il mondo il mondo
fisico il mondo reale accadde quella
magia quella magia che si chiama
trasformazione digitale e quindi essendo
al centro di una trasformazione digitale
così veloce è molto probabile che le
minacce del futuro
saranno totalmente differenti da quelle
che noi oggi conosciamo è il paradigma
che noi oggi difensori utilizziamo è un
paradigma basato sull'attacco quindi
cerchiamo di immedesimarci nella mente
dell'attaccante per riuscire a capire
quello che sta facendo
ma forse ci sono altri metodi
ma forse ma forse ci saranno altri
strumenti che dovremo utilizzare che
dovremmo andare a studiare
forse ci possono essere anche
altri temi da esplorare prima di
utilizzare quelli già quelli già
conosciuti
in fondo oggi se ci pensate quello che
abbiamo fatto è stato un percorso un
percorso artistico siamo partiti da un
oggetto
astratto o meglio non visualizzabile e
poi attraverso degli algoritmi di
visione artificiale siamo riusciti a
ottenere una sua visione e con degli
algoritmi
di intelligenza artificiale stiamo
cercando di capire se possiamo prevedere
come sarà ecco allora la domanda che
vorrei lasko la quale vorrei lasciarvi a
questo non potrebbe essere
l'arte un ambiente dove andare a trovare
la prossima soluzione
o meglio potrebbe essere l'arte massima
espressione dell'umanità a salvare il
digitale
grazie
[Applauso]